hello all thank you for being patient in
my weekend hiatus of no videos because I
went back and visited friends and family
I just needed to do that but now it is
mundane in the words of Saruman we have
works which means I woke up to news
authority rock trailers and hit the
internet which is necessary and I needed
to see this I wanted to see it now it's
not let's talk about it it starts out
Chris Hemsworth is wrapped up in chains
and he's pretty much like this is this
story all about how my life got flipped
turned upside down
do you see hella and baddies coming in
and just wiping out Asgard he throws
meal there at her head and she just goes
BAM and holds it and then crushes it
Mjolnir is gone Thor has no hammer hope
they can find the heart of another dying
star to forge another one otherwise it's
just that's gone now I'll be on as well
I'll be transferred I don't know much
about the whole Ragnarok thing with
Helen I don't know hella is supposedly
did God use gods an [ __ ] will break
her hammer can we get to address the
fact that that is Cate Blanchet I
totally forgot Cate Blanchett was in
this movie I forgot she was hella then I
saw that no blur ooh who's the hot chick
loves me some sex evil then I realized
in Cate Blanchet I write the irony being
Cate Blanchett was in The Curious Case
of Benjamin Button and Cate Blanchett
herself gets younger and younger for
every year that passes seriously what is
she 30 max she's like Asgard is no more
than out Thor gets captured and he's
made to fight in arena with Jeff
Goldblum and the rest of the neon
painted armored folks from destiny same
color palette it look like destiny folks
which is why this trailer needed to
happen for me I saw the pictures of
Goldblum pictures of Thor and I was like
looks very different so I figured it was
something I needed to see in motion and
in motion I like what I think
I wish Loki's helmet had covered his
whole head like before I mean Thor's
helmet is pretty much Thoris Ally I
don't know if he got that from Gollum
and the rest of the destiny but his
helmet just reminded me of Orion from
Wonder Woman so I like about this
trailers it brings context to the new
color scheme and the outfits and the
haircut or I was like so everything in
Asgard is just different now why so now
we see why it's not Asgard it's another
Society of people and that that's how
they are so when Thor's getting ready to
fight as I write whatever comes through
that door I'm gonna have to fight it and
you here goes one like here is your
incredible boom hulk comes through and
Planet Hulk armor Thor's like yeah
ever like what ye I'm confused he was
supposed to be afraid damn it a lion
who's like I know him he's a friend from
work and then they charge at each other
and they fight and you know that fight
is going to be the coolest fight I mean
Hulk Buster and Hulk was a pretty big
fight but this fistfight is going to be
a pretty sweet one no hammer trickery
this time hopes not gonna waste this
time trying to pick up a hammer it's
busted wait wait now that Muller is
busted can anyone pick up the pieces of
the hammer or the piece is just going to
be there is it the hammer as a hole that
people can't pick up unless the worthy
or do the scraps count if so it's like
boom hammer chunks damn I guess I'll
have to build a floor over it just no
one can pick up the chunks these are the
things to think about when you're going
to bust those hammer cut to the titles
it looks like far cry 3 Blood Dragon and
now we have a trailer for Thor Ragnarok
looks pretty good though this trailer
really subsided my concerns from the
weird ventures I saw earlier and made me
go okay let's watch more fight Hulk in
the arena
Thor's world gets invaded if not wiped
out Thor needs to fight in an arena I
imagine he and Hulk are going to team up
to take out the [ __ ] that wiped out
his world you don't do have Thor's world
when he has his big green friend and get
away with it while Thor's brother Loki
watches him fight Hulk next to paint it
up Brundle flies not nice so yeah solid
glad I got a trailer glad I can put
context to the imagery let's bring on
Thor Ragnarok but for you guys the Thor
Ragnarok trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it you have concerns
with the images that this trailer give
context and subside those concerns of
regions like yeah on board the entire
time or are you still not on board at
all whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right there that's a Moy
[Music]